you were a zombie in warm bodies now
talk about an acting challenge i think
being a zombie must be very difficult
yeah yeah i mean it had its upsides i
didn't have a lot of lines to learn um
oh that's true yeah yeah so it's easy
you can just mutter and moan emotion it
was kind of you know what
yeah one of my friends was laughing
about it he was like you know what it's
kind of the easiest role you've probably
ever had to roll like an uncharismatic
pale guy who moans a lot and then
slouches when he walked he was like you
didn't have to do anything for that yeah
yeah
so you thought like okay that's pretty
easy what about there's a lot of uh
technical stuff when you're playing a
zombie like
you have to i'm sure it's a spec this
great special effect they have but you
have to eat people you know yeah i don't
i never understand how that works like
how does that work well that was the i
mean the main brain eating for me and
that was uh was dave franco's brains um
and he didn't want to do it for real for
whatever reason so
um he chickened out yeah what a whim
didn't want to do it um so we got this
dummy uh that looked not really much
like him to be honest and i would i
would crack its head and then i'd peel
its skull off and eat his brains um
which was really fun apart from the one
time when um and what is the brains made
of is it made of like marzipan or candy
cakey sort of thing in there it's quite
sweet with lots of fake blood um but
it's tasty yeah no it's tasty apart from
the one time when the dummy's hair got
pulled off and it was mixed in with the
brains
and i sat there and looked at it i saw
it and i was like i knew it take i know
it took a while to reset this this skull
so i thought you know what i'm just
going to eat the hair
what sorry
i hate it i don't know why no no that's
where you say cut there's hair in the
brain yeah i know we got to reset and do
it again i'll be in my trailer for seven
things but
getting a massage watching football
that's what you do yeah i know i felt as
i felt as though i've taken one for the
team i was like if i do this everyone
can go home early and and they won't be
stuck here for another half hour or
whatever so were they proud of you when
you just ate like six pounds of hair no
i was like i was like quietly heroic i
never mentioned it till now so hopefully
now i get lots of messages being like
wow
you're amazing
i don't think you'll get one
uh i know that you were
just in africa and you tried did you try
skydiving for the first time and i did
yeah yeah i've never you know i got a
story about that
and about this guy that went up 24
months oh forgot
oh you're watching i'm sorry
you you jumped out of a plane yeah i've
never been tempted for a second to do
that oh i was i was terrified throughout
and i i've spent the whole morning
thinking i was doing everything for the
last time so i was brushing my teeth and
i was like this is the last time i've
cleaned my teeth and then driving in the
car is that this is the last time in the
car and then i got i got there and they
they showed the different jumpsuits they
had lined up
and there was one in uh in tiger print
like a onesie with tiger print with a
little hood and little ears and
everything and i i sat there and i
looked at it i was like that's the one
that's the one that made it i was like
why why
in my head i was like you know what if i
am going to die today at least then
everyone you know who knows me can be
like ah it's a shame he died but at
least like there's a funny kind of
morbid twist on it yeah and like they
could have like at the funeral they can
have a little laugh it's like oh yeah
such a nick thing to do yeah and also
and also kind of think like you know you
know not feel so sorry for you yeah the
man dressed as a toy i think we have a
picture here of you there you are wow
that's fantastic yeah i didn't have the
hood up then but it did have little ears
as well it's very cute uh i want to make
sure we get to this jack the giant
slayer yeah and uh
uh the the special effects look
fantastic there's no brain eating for
you in this no no no this is me running
around swashbuckling um with these
fantastic bill nye he plays the lead
lead giant and and they did motion
capture and there's amazing special
effects in it it's it's odd seeing a
film like that because most of the stuff
isn't there when you're there and then
suddenly you see it
you're just uh acting on a green screen
yeah yeah we're going to do the talk
show like that someday just it's all
going to be done from monday from home
yeah i'll just do it from home and andy
will do it from his home and kevin will
be at his home and we'll just all beam
us in and we'll do the show that would
be great that's a great idea conan
oh it is i think it's a good idea yeah i
think it's a great invited back